I'll actually just quickly show some of this stuff.
Okay, so we got a little actor here with a widget component on it.
So if I just quickly jump into this, you can see this is just an actor I've made with a widget component on it.
As you might assume, because this widget can exist in space, this is a scene component,
therefore it's part of the scene component hierarchy.
Therefore, all the things that apply to it would apply here.
So their position is described relatively to the thing that they're attached to, etc, etc.
You've got all these various properties.
You can specify a material that's used for this widget.
Like we said, this is our world or screen space.
This is the widget that we're actually using, our draw size.
This is actually quite an important element, particularly when you're in world space,
because this kind of means two things at once.
One is the actual canvas that is used to draw this thing.
So if I were to create some kind of example widget, this were just a border,
and we're going to make it some horribly garish color, like vibrant magenta,
and then put an image in the top left.
And that's just going to be just going to give it some kind of icon, this thing.
And then I want to specify that as our 3D widget.
You can really see how this would kind of come in.
So I'm just going to do new widget blueprint.
You can see that our widget actually being displayed.
But if I were to adjust this such that our draw size were more like 1000 by 500,
you can see our actual icon.
It's not like our widget has scaled up.
It's just the kind of window it's being drawn into is larger.
So it's just kind of worth bearing that in mind and understanding what kind of consequences that is going to have.
It doesn't always mean the content is going to get bigger.
It just means that the space that the content is getting drawn into is bigger.
So it kind of very much depends on how you've set your widget up for whether or not that is going to work.
If I go back to 3D widget, which is what this is actually set up for, and I change that back to 300 by 200.
Like I said, this means kind of two things.
So one is the kind of space that you have.
The other thing is that draw size maps directly to how big it is in world, as you've kind of already seen.
So the standard implementation is each pixel here is one unreal unit.
And therefore a 300 by 200 widget is going to be three metres wide, two metres tall.
If you don't want that to be the relationship, if you don't want it to be one unit is one centimetre,
the only way I'm aware of changing that is by changing the scale of the component.
I don't normally advise scaling components, avoiding it whenever you can.
But I'm not aware of another way to change the kind of ratio of draw size to actual size in world
other than to change the scale of the component.
But there may be other ways that I'm not aware of.
Like I said, we've got our pivot here, so this is saying the centre of our component is going to be the centre of the widget.
So if I kind of just briefly demonstrate that.
OK, well, that's not actually showing my way.
Oh, no, probably is actually. If I change this to 300 by 100,
that probably actually is where the component is.
Yeah, it's just that this widget is again not actually taking up that much space.
So it's kind of just getting pushed into the top left.
So if I were to change this to be more like 200 by 50, let's say.
Yeah, that's a little bit more like it.
So you can see our pivot is pretty much over the centre of the thing.
That's the only reason it's not is just because I haven't actually accurately matched the size of the widget itself.
But if I were to change our pivot to be 0.51, you could see it's not like less is being drawn, but it's just that the geometry is kind of being pushed up.
Where is the kind of jump that the box that represents our widget would be kind of more like here.
Whereas when the pivot is 0.5, 0.5, it would be drawn more like here.
And you can kind of guess what a pivot of zero is going to do.
It's going to offset it to the left.
So the left side starts where the component position is.
So that's the effect of the pivot.
So you can see the obvious benefits here.
There are plenty of games that would utilise this kind of 3D widget drawing functionality.
We've seen things like Dead Space with this kind of diegetic UIs, something like Splinter Style Conviction for apparently all my game references are really old for some kind of spatial UIs and stuff like that.
You can imagine lots and lots of cool functionalities here.
But the kind of other side of this coin is that once a widget is actually 3D in world, maybe you want the capability to actually interact with it.
Maybe we want to go like full diegetic and these are actual screens in world that you can interact with.
And that's where the widget interaction component comes in.
This essentially gives us the functionality for a player to interact with 3D widgets in world.
Like I already said, it sits on the player portal character and it's driven by traces and this component can actually simulate key presses.
Let me just actually just demonstrate this quickly.
So we've got this.
That's actually what this demo scene is for.
We've got this widget trace of Pawn.
If I just quickly jump inside that, you can see how this is set up.
We've just got a standard.
This just inherits from character.
So it's got all the standard character stuff, but it's just got this additional widget interactive component on it, which has a couple of different things to be worth bearing in mind.
First off, we have a virtual user index, which is essentially which user should we pretend this widget is interacting on behalf of.
Essentially, the widget interact component pretends that they were like a UI user and it just turns our 3D scans into kind of like pretending there's like a mouse cursor or something like that over this widget geometry.
So which user should it pretend to be?
Pointer index is relevant if you're doing kind of like touch based inputs where you might have like, you know, multiple fingers.
So the pointer index is which kind of finger should it represent.
By standard, if you're just doing kind of mouse things, it's going to remain at zero.
We have the trace channel, which is essentially because this is all being done off all of this logic works off traces.
Which channel should we be using the trace against this?
The thing that this needs to pair up with is you need to make sure this is a channel that the 3D widget you're going to be interacting with actually blocks.
If we go to our 3D widget, the standard collision setup for any 3D widget is a collision preset of UI.
And if we look at what that preset looks like, it overlaps every channel apart from visibility, which it blocks.
Obviously, if that's not completely suitable for your game's needs, you could create like a UI trace channel and have your widget interaction trace on that and have your UI block that.
But visibility is fine for this situation.
Interaction distant, pretty self-explanatory, so it'll only trace this far.
Any widget that's further than that, it won't detect.
And then we've got this quite interesting setting here, which is essentially what's the logic that we use for where to draw this trace from?
So all of these settings are pretty self-explanatory, but world will trace from the location of our component in the direction that our component is facing, regardless of where we put that component.
So we could detach it from our player, we could fly around the scene, it's just wherever that component is.
Mouse, we'll interpret the mouse location of our first local player, because really there can only be one mouse anyway.
And turn that into screen space and draw a line from that, into world space, sorry.
Take that screen space position, turn it into world space and draw a line from that.
Center of screen is kind of the same idea, just the center of the screen of our first local player controller.
And then we have custom where we can essentially provide a custom function that will specify if we need gameplay to drive this in some way.
But most of the time when you're trying to do that, you could just be setting the world location of the component, and that's probably going to be a little bit more clear what you're actually trying to do.
So if we just go for center of screen.
The other thing to mention is that you've got this show debug functionality, which is a very easy and helpful way to demonstrate when this is actually working.
So if we go here, you can see when I'm in range of the widget, my cursor starts appearing.
You see it appears a little bit above and below, and that's because our widget geometry is actually slightly larger than the widget itself.
This is this whole, you know, the fact that it's 50 pixels tall, even though this thing is probably only 30 pixels tall or something.
And if I left click, it actually appears as a window.
Now, all the options aren't displaying because now my window isn't big enough.
So if I just quickly go back and change that to however many pixels tall it was before, I think it was like 200.
Now, if I do that again, you can see all this extra space at the bottom because this is technically the plane is here.
But this particular bit of the widget just isn't over it.
But now when I click, I get all my options and I can interact with these.
And this works literally like a normal UI.
This could work as a UI button and I'm interacting with it exactly like that.
So the only other kind of piece of this puzzle, we've got all this functionality set up for where the widget is, what trace channel it's drawing on.
The only other thing is to make our widget actually try and interact when we left click, which is done in our event graph of our player controller.
You can see we've just got a little bit of setup for movement and turning.
And the key component here is that on our left mouse button, on the widget interaction component itself, we call this press pointer key.
And on let go, we do release pointer key.
And it's this that is kind of funneling this input down through our widget interaction component as though it were coming through our mouse.
You can also actually funnel keyboard keys through press pointer key, so it's not exclusively limited to keyboard keys.
But yeah, that's just worth mentioning.
In previous games, I've actually used this to do like interactive PC screens.
You can imagine a whole bunch of implementations for this that aren't just clicking on a button hovering in the world.
So yeah, very powerful and you can have a lot of fun with that.
So now we're kind of at the end of the kind of more formal structure bit of the talk.
And there's just a couple of other things I just wanted to mention before we finally get to the end.
Obviously, UMG is a huge topic here.
But there's just a couple of things that if you're starting out in UMG, there's a couple of things to kind of be aware of and look out for.
This isn't really the talk to kind of go into detail about each of these things.
But just if you're starting to utilize UMG, there's a couple of little things that you can hit up against that can get really confusing.
So I just thought were worth very, very briefly mentioning.
Hence the kind of huge slightly distorted list.
So first off, DPI scaling.
One of the things when you're putting UIs onto screens, you might encounter situations where your UI seems to think it's one size or it's drawing at one size.
It doesn't necessarily make sense.
I've got a little demo scene that demonstrates this.
Again, this project is downloadable, so you can kind of jump in here and see everything I'm doing.
But if I go to a map and go to a DPI scale example, you can see as I play, I'm putting a widget onto my screen and I'm printing the different sizes of it.
We've got the local size, so the widget, the size of the widget itself thinks it is.
So it thinks it's 1880 by 1080, which is like not crazy far off.
But this is, you know, I'm on a 1080 monitor.
This screen is clearly not 1080 pixels high, right?
This whole monitor is 1080 pixels high.
So that's clearly a little bit off and weird.
The absolute size is a little bit closer, probably.
But this would get a little bit weirder if you've got a multi monitor set up and it's in a different location.
Or maybe you've got a window and it's kind of like, you know, off to the side here.
It's going to be describing something a little bit different.
A kind of viewport size.
So this is, again, kind of close, but not necessarily completely right.
And then the desired size of our widget.
And then we've got this other value, which is our scale.
So if I just kind of start changing this a little bit, you see these numbers changing.
And in an extreme case, you can see that, like, clearly the size of my widget is like something's going wrong here, right?
Because it thinks it's 2300 pixels wide, which is like my monitor literally cannot display that resolution.
And the reason for that and the reason that you may be getting kind of weird sizing issues where your UIs don't seem to be at the size that they think they are
is down to this thing, this concept called DPI scaling.
Essentially, DPI scaling is something, it's not a bug.
Its intended functionality is to make sure that your UIs, you author them at one size,
but obviously they need to be able to work on screens of lots of different sizes.
You know, the standard is 1920 by 1080, but some people only have access to 720 screens.
Some people are still on 1024 by 768 screens.
Some people are on 4K.
So you don't want your UI to only work on the one resolution that you authored it for.
So that's where DPI scaling comes in.
What DPI scaling actually does is it reads the shortest side of your screen
and essentially takes that and puts it into a function to establish how much should we scale this screen by.
So when I say the shortest side, you can see that is either width or height, whichever is shorter.
And you can see this happening because as I get square, eventually when it stops being square
and it starts being thinner rather than tall, you'll see my scale changing.
And now that it's thinner than tall, my scale is now going down.
And it's at the point that I reach the point of equilibrium.
It now stays static.
So I do mean it when I say the shortest side.
It's at runtime, whichever of the two sides is shorter.
And this is in the project settings.
If you just look for DPI scale, there is literally an engine user interface.
There's literally a graph here that says what's the standard application scale,
what's the rule it should use, by default it's the shortest side.
And essentially this is just, as you can see, a pretty linear curve.
You can see it's got keys at the kind of standard resolutions.
So 1080, 720.
Again, we're keying the shortest side here.
So our 1920 and 1080, which of those two numbers is smaller.
And what scale should that map to?
So when your screen is 1080, the scale is 1.
When your shortest side is 720, the scale is 0.6.
And all the things in between.
And you may have noticed that the scale stopped at 0.44444.
And that's because there are no more keys on this curve.
But yeah, it's just worth noting that DPI scale is a thing.
Here is where you can tweak it if you ever need to do that and just be aware of it.
The widget reflector we've kind of already talked about.
This is basically a very, very powerful debugging tool
that gives you the ability to debug UIs at runtime.
You can do this in...
Let's just go to a more complicated example.
So if I open up my widget reflector,
I can do that through a console command,
or you can do it through your UMG window as we saw.
There's a whole bunch of things,
but the key thing that I tend to use a lot
is you've got this option here where you can pick a widget on your screen.
So you can either pick a hit testable widget,
so this widget is kind of visible,
or you can pick a painted widget,
so one that you can just see.
And you can hover over anything
and you can see all this information updating in the middle of my box.
And then whenever I want to, I can hit escape
and it stops trying to read whichever widget I'm over
and kind of just freezes on the last one I had selected.
And then you can look into your details panel,
all the information about that.
You can see the full hierarchy.
Obviously, this is absolutely gigantic,
so you might need to drag this over
to get a more full picture of your hierarchy.
Some other bits of information that are quite useful here
is you can also filter this.
So if you go to filter,
because this is going all the way up to your Unreal root screen,
you can actually see all the different bits of it getting focused.
So here's the point where it's actually inside my Unreal editor.
That's the border up here.
You can see this is our game overlay.
Then we're inside the level editor.
And all of this stuff says what classes is it?
What visibility state is it in?
So if you have widgets that don't seem to be appearing,
you could use the widget editor to see,
are they tinted the wrong color?
Are they there, but they're kind of off screen?
What's going on?
Are they even added to this hierarchy?
This is obviously, all of this hierarchy here
is just the visible hierarchy.
So anything that isn't actually added to the screen,
you won't be able to debug through this.
But you can even use this to look at things actually in the editor itself
to be like, oh, I really, I wonder how they did that widget setup.
And you can use this to kind of focus on these things
and kind of see how it's being constructed.
So it's very, very useful kind of not just debugging tool,
but also kind of like archeology tool, I suppose.
The other kind of useful thing is, like I said,
you can filter all of this down to be like,
I don't care about any of the editor functionality.
I just want to start at the point that UMG is.
And that gives us the ability to kind of really trim down
the number of widgets we're talking about.
And also, if you still have a very complex hierarchy,
you can be like, oh, I don't care about any of this stuff.
I want to filter down to this specific node
and only worry about what's within this.
And as I said, you can go through individual widgets
and kind of like debug them, look at their various details
and also see which widget is highlighted
whenever you're talking about these various things.
This is the vertical box and this is the geometry it has.
It's a little bit difficult to see
because these things are currently white.
But you can see as I'm hovering over the text box,
we get the block around there.
So, yeah, widget reflector,
very, very powerful debugging tool.
Be aware that it's there, use it liberally.
Gamepad navigation and focus.
This is quite a deep topic.
But all I'm going to say is that there is a kind of set,
a map in this example that just shows you
how you might handle gamepad input
because this is a kind of standard thing
that's a little bit underserved in Unreal documentation.
So there's a little example level set up
for how you can handle gamepad focus.
We essentially put a widget on screen.
The key thing is basically just focusing a widget.
And at that point, a lot of the behaviour
will kind of just work.
You just kind of need to know how navigation works in Unreal.
So I'm just going to actually connect up my gamepad.
Just give me one second.
So if I play, the kind of key things to bear in mind
is that you set focus.
And if I just stop play and start again.
But you also bear in mind that certain widgets
have a kind of navigation logic to them,
like a vertical box or a scroll box
will look for the next entry within them.
But the default navigation behaviour,
I'm just using my left stick on my gamepad here.
I haven't done any special custom setup to facilitate this.
The default logic basically does
what is a little bit like ray tracing.
So the way you navigate between widgets
using gamepad by default
is that they just need to overlap in some way.
So if, for example, I go from this widget
and I try and navigate right,
you'll see it skips over that widget in the middle
and finds the next widget
that kind of literally overlaps with it.
So it'll jump all the way there.
If there were nothing overlapping with it,
it would not navigate at all.
So it just wouldn't work.
So just be aware that your sizes
and your overlapping is actually quite relevant here.
And also, you can interject bits of widgetry
that aren't even focusable
and it doesn't necessarily interrupt the flow.
So the fact that this text block
is in the middle between these two buttons
doesn't necessarily matter.
But the things that do matter,
the only things that you can navigate to
are things that are, A, focusable,
because things to receive gamepad focus
need to be focusable.
And the other thing they need to be is visible,
i.e. hit testable.
We talked about those various settings available before.
Visible is the only one that basically says
this can be clicked on by the mouse
or can be found by gamepad
by kind of navigation like this.
So you can kind of see this proven.
We've got this couple of buttons here.
The blue buttons are visible but not focusable.
The green buttons are visible and focusable.
And the red buttons are focusable but not visible.
So no combination of visible and not focusable
or focusable and not visible works.
It has to be both.
But the important thing is here,
if I go to actually this button,
you can see that the kind of visible
and focusable bit of this
is actually deep into the hierarchy.
So the parent, this actual widget itself,
isn't focusable.
The widget itself isn't visible.
But this button within it is.
The navigation doesn't care where this widget lies.
It just, as in it cares geometrically where it lies,
but it doesn't care about where it lies in the hierarchy.
It will just find a widget that is focusable and visible.
So when the navigation occurs,
it will navigate to this explicit widget within here.
This widget is not the one being focused.
This is the one being focused.
There are events that you can bind in the tree
to say, you know, added to focus path.
So you can see that being used here.
That's basically to say, I'm not the one being focused,
but something beneath me is being focused.
One of my children is being focused.
And you can use that to kind of do visual feedback.
So you can see I'm doing that here
to kind of highlight this border in pink
when this button has been focused.
So that's just a very, very quick intro to gamepad focus.
Another two things that are kind of, again, underserved
in terms of explanations is the idea of this,
the viewport client and the slate application file.
Just be aware that these are classes that exist
The game viewport client is essentially the entry point
for any input going into the game.
The first entry point for all input into Unreal at all
is through the slate application.
I think I talked about this
in maybe the second session very briefly.
But basically, whenever we're dealing with input,
input goes first into slate application.
And the first thing it will try and do
is funnel it into your UI.
And again, it will use that same flow
that I talked about with our input focus
where it will go down to the widget that you have focused.
So in the case that we had here,
if I press the A button,
it will go to the button I literally have focused.
And as it happens,
that button is actually handling my gamepad A button.
And so you can see it kind of flickering.
That's because it's reacting to me pressing the button.
But if it weren't handling that,
naturally, that input would,
if we look at the hierarchy,
the input would bubble up to this border
to see if it can do anything with that button.
It wouldn't.
It would go up to here
to see if it does anything with it.
And in the context of being inside this whole widget hierarchy,
wherever that setup is,
focus navigation,
in the context of this button or whatever it was,
it would go up to here,
and then here, and then here,
all the way up to your game viewport,
and eventually it gets up to your viewport itself.
And it is only at that point
that it gets to your viewport,
if the rest of your in-game UI hasn't handled that input,
if the UI is what has focus this is,
then it will get to your viewport,
and the point that it goes to your viewport,
then it will, if you're in an input mode
that is either game only or game and UI,
then that input will then get focused
into your game viewport client,
and it will then go down into your game,
and that's where you then get input
for movement controls, turning your camera,
whatever standard game input you like.
So input goes first to UI,
and then goes to game if you're in an input mode.
And that brings us to our various input modes,
which I'm very briefly going to show off.
So there are three input modes you can be in.
These are functions that you call on the player controller.
Set input mode.
So these are three input modes you can be in.
The standard is game and UI.
Then we also have game only and UI only.
UI only means you set focus to a particular widget,
and if input gets to your viewport,
it doesn't go to your game viewport client.
It never goes to your game.
It basically just turns that functionality off.
Game only means that we focus your viewport.
We're not expecting any input to go to any other UI.
It goes straight to your viewport,
and then it will funnel through to your game viewport client.
And game and UI, which is the standard,
means that we go to UI first,
let UI try and handle it.
If UI hasn't handled it,
it eventually bubbles up to the viewport,
and then funnels that input to your game viewport.
So the two kind of real key classes in all of this flow
are, again, your slate application file,
where all of this input starts,
and your game viewport client is the point at which
input has gone into your game.
It's first been checked against UI,
and just depending on your input,
depending on whether or not any of the UI handles that input,
it will then eventually bubble through to your viewport
and then make it to your viewport client
if you're not in input mode UI only.
Cached geometry is something that's just kind of worth knowing about.
This is basically just in UMG,
whenever you're in the UMG editor,
or in C++.
You can get information about a widget,
about the kind of like space that it occupies on screen.
So if you just do get cached,
am I inside a widget? I'm not.
Get cached geometry.
And you can basically query a whole bunch of data about this.
You can be like,
where is this widget on screen?
How much space does it occupy?
Is this widget overlapping another widget?
Is my mouse overlapping this widget?
It's just worth knowing that this is here.
It basically lets you do mathematical things
with that widget's kind of space that it takes up on screen.
The only thing that's worth mentioning about it
is that it's often kind of a frame behind.
So your cached geometry is probably going to be
always one frame out of date.
Unless you're doing something highly dynamic,
most of the time that doesn't matter,
but it's just worth mentioning.
Yeah, I think I already kind of demonstrated this a little bit,
but there are two kind of like ease of life,
little shortcuts that are worth knowing about
when you're doing stuff in the hierarchy,
that if you have a widget
and you kind of want to interject something
between these two things,
you can do wrap with,
and that will put a widget,
will put this widget inside another widget,
but give that widget all of the details this had.
So you can see this horizontal box is at position 760244
and has these sizes.
If I wrap this with a border,
you can see now that border is at position 760244,
those sizes,
and the horizontal box is within it.
And then if you accidentally made a mistake
and you kind of want to remove that,
what you can do is you can do replace with,
and this lets you swap that widget
for a different kind of widget,
or quite powerfully you can say replace this with a child.
This essentially says put this back where this thing is
and give it all the details that it had.
So replace with,
and you can see we're back to the horizontal box
having the same slot details.
I've already talked about this a little bit,
but just bear in mind
that different widgets have different costs.
There's a really good talk from Adrian Pugh
who I'll talk about in a second
who kind of goes into a little bit more details about this.
There's also some good posts on what was previously Twitter
about this kind of stuff.
It comes up occasionally.
Basically different widgets do cost different things.
The kind of thing to particularly watch out for
is overlaying widgets over the top of each other.
So the kind of two go-to panels that people think of using
are canvas panels and overlays.
Both of these are quite expensive.
Canvas panels are the worst offenders.
And the same thing with animations.
We've talked about the widget animation system.
It's very powerful, gives you a lot of control,
but it is probably the most expensive way
to animate a widget.
The second, the kind of more efficient way
to animate a widget is just through Blueprint code.
So if you can affect its position just in code
or be that Blueprint code or C++.
And even more efficiently is do it all through materials,
which kind of brings us onto the retainer widget
because that lets us utilize materials as well.
But just to kind of quickly show this,
images in UMG don't just have to use textures.
Sorry if I just put an image here.
They can also use materials.
So you can see I've got my material options here.
I think I made a kind of, yeah,
I've made a material image here.
And you can see I've just plugged in this
some funky UI material.
And this gives you the ability to have dynamic imagery.
And if you do animations through your material,
that's immensely more performant than animations
any other way.
So if you can do that,
that's going to save you a lot of CPU cycles.
Then the retainer widget,
when we're talking about efficiency,
the retainer widget is definitely an element
that can come in here.
This is going to deserve its own talk in itself.
But just know that retainer widget is a thing.
If I put a retainer box in my,
I'm going to wrap this widget.
Let's do it around our new widget
so I'm not mucking up too much of stuff
I've already done.
Wrap this with a retainer box.
So the retainer widget has a couple of different functionalities.
One thing it lets you do
is basically turn off rendering for the widgets below it
so that it controls these things.
So that your widgets aren't perpetually repositioning themselves,
re-updating, re-visualizing.
If you have a widget that you know will only update
for a certain period of time
or will snap between different states,
you kind of don't need all of that
laying out rendering functionality the rest of the time.
This is a little bit like dormancy in networking.
It's kind of the same, but for widget rendering.
So the retainer gives us control over that thing.
It lets us say how frequently should this thing update
or do we even just go to more of an event-based rendering
where I'll tell you when to update
and we just don't update otherwise.
But the other thing that the retainer widget lets you do
is act as almost like a post-process.
So if you have this effect material,
what this will essentially do is
if you pass in a material here,
you can pass in a texture parameter name
and the retainer widget will feed in a texture to a parameter
with whatever name you specify here.
And the texture that it feeds in
will be basically a picture of all the widgets within it.
So it gives the ability to do really cool post-process effects
of whatever you can imagine.
It basically takes you to take a snapshot
of all the widgets within this retainer box
and do screen space modifications to them.
So you can imagine how powerful that could be.
Just worth mentioning that it's there.
Editor widgets.
This is kind of straying into an entirely different topic
of editor functionality, but just worth mentioning
that you can create custom widgets
for your own editor purposes.
These are tools that you can expose to your designers,
to whoever, and you can make widgets for them
and kind of run editor time functions.
You could make an editor widget for positioning all your actors
in a nice clean row if that's something you needed
or whatever, any kind of tool you can imagine.
You can make an editor widget for it,
which is a widget that has access to editor specific functionality.
You can talk to your editor systems.
You can edit data in your level at editor time.
It's just worth noting that those things exist.
UI extension points.
When we're talking about adding editor functionality,
one of the other things you might want to do is start,
at some point you may want to start creating your own tools
and one of the things you might wonder is like,
oh, I want to add another button to this window
or how do I just add another thing to the select section?
Essentially, everything within Unreal
is kind of represented by some kind of points
that you can hook things onto.
The way you can actually visualize these,
they're kind of basically a bunch of secret names
that represent all of the hook points
you can attach these things to.
If you go into your editor preferences
and you go to all settings, you search for extension.
There's this option here called display UI extension points.
If you tick that, it'll ask you to restart the editor
but when you do that, your editor will be blanketed
with lots of green text everywhere
and these will basically show you all the secret cheat code names
for where all these hook points are
and you can then use those when writing your,
you'd have to have a editor module for your project.
This would all be C++ code
but you could then hook in your own custom windows.
You could add buttons to custom tabs and stuff like that
and that's all using these editor extension hook points.
When we're talking about editor functionality
and adding your UI, it's also worth mentioning
a couple of extra plugins here.
The first one is user toolbox.
If you are thinking about doing your own custom UIs,
it's worth mentioning that there is a kind of plugin
available already called user toolbox
that lets you basically just quickly add custom editor widgets
and editor bits of functionality to a kind of toolbox
that is easily available to all of your designers.
This is just one of those examples of like
you think about some kind of like cool feature or system
and it turns out Unreal has actually already done it.
So if you do start thinking about adding editor windows
or editor tools that you want to position around the UI,
do look at user toolbox first
because you could save yourself a little bit of time there.
When I've talked about gamepad functionality and stuff like that,
there are a lot of problems that you commonly come up against
whether it's like gamepad navigation,
whether it's displaying widgets in a way
such that you can kind of display widget A over widget B
and then you need to be able to return to widget B
once you close widget A.
There are these common problems that you kind of tackle again and again and again
when you're doing UMG stuff with Unreal.
A lot of those problems have actually already been solved
by an epic development plugin called Common UI.
It's very powerful. It's very, very feature rich.
It would be too big to kind of go into talking about right now
but it's a plugin that's been developed and shipped with Fortnite
so it's kind of quite thoroughly battle tested.
Absolutely spend some time looking into it.
The links to all three of these plugins that I'm about to talk about now
are in this presentation by the way
so if you kind of forget the names or whatever, the links are there.
And the last one to mention is MVVM.
This stands for Model View ViewModel
which is not a real specific term.
For anyone who's used to using kind of proprietary UI technology,
things like Scaleform and stuff like that,
you might be used to this system where
your UI is kind of this independent piece of software
that you kind of send information to and you get information back from
and what you might have is this kind of like contractual mediator
where there's this bit of information that sits between your game
and the actual UI where both the UI and the game kind of agree on this thing
and the UI doesn't actually have to know about what the game is doing
and the game doesn't have to know about what the UI is doing.
They both just kind of write into and read from this kind of mediated central bit of data.
This is an implementation of really something that's called the mediator pattern.
And that can definitely be a desirable set of functionality
for people who just want that separation of concerns between gameplay and UI.
These two things don't have to know about each other.
It makes things very reusable because multiple things can use the same view model.
It means that your UI team don't necessarily have to communicate
quite as much with your dev team
because your UI team can set up the view model that they need
and then pass that over to the gameplay team
and they can just plug the right values into that view model.
So it lets you kind of break things up
and it means that the teams don't necessarily have to be waiting on each other as much,
which can be very desirable depending on your setup.
So just know that MVVM is a plugin that's available that implements this.
Whereas Common UI is battle-tested and shipped for Fortnite,
MVVM is definitely experimental
and I think the current advice is do not ship titles with this plugin,
but by the time you've been developing a project with this for two years,
that could change.
So just know that it's there
and it does provide quite a lot of useful functionality.
The last thing is there's a couple of UMG-specific resources.
There's a whole bunch of links actually part of this presentation,
but just a couple of key points that I'd want to bring up.
There's an Unreal developer who goes by the handle Ben UI.
He's got a website dedicated to Unreal stuff,
but specifically a lot of it is geared more to UMG stuff,
but it is also just useful Unreal stuff content.
He gave a talk for JetBrains
where he basically spent a bit of time demystifying
some of the kind of weird terminology and macros around Slate.
So for anyone who is interested in looking to Slate functionality
and how these things actually work,
it's worth checking that talk out.
That talk is actually hosted on his website,
so if you just go to Ben UI's website, you will find it.
Adrian Pugh is an Unreal developer
who's worked a lot on...
I think she spent some time working on Fortnite,
but does a lot of UMG stuff.
She's got several Unreal Fest talks,
particularly two from Unreal Gold Coast 2024
that were very, very good, one about common UI,
one about 20 underused features in Unreal in UMG.
And she's also got her own website of Joyrock
where she does some just cool UMG material stuff
so you can see some of the functionalities.
And then lastly, when we're talking about UMG materials,
it's worth mentioning the UI Material Lab,
which is an Unreal example project.
It's available on Fab Marketplace through the Unreal launcher.
It's a very, very cool demonstration
about some of the really cool material stuff
that you can do with UI
and some of the performance gains you can get
and some of the cool bits of functionality you can bake in,
as well as a whole host of kind of like time savers
for things you very often need to do,
like circular progress bars and stuff like that.
They've got a lot of those implementations
for how you could achieve things
and you can kind of just recycle
some of these things yourself in your own games.
And there's also a very, very good run through of this
actually in an Unreal live stream,
which is done by kind of one of the devs
who was responsible for it.
Again, all the links for these contents
are available in the presenter notes for this presentation.
So if you download this presentation,
you'll find those links,
but you can also just look these things up
and you'll definitely find them.
So that about wraps everything up.
That was a huge wad of kind of like miscellaneous things
at the end,
but I just thought all of these things
are worth mentioning,
especially if you're getting started out.
You don't want to get caught out
by some of these gotchas.
We've gone over the fundamentals.
We've gone over into some of the little details.
I think that about wraps us up.